Satoshi Nakamoto invented
bitcoin and more importantly,
it's underlying blockchain technology.
No matter what the
future price of bitcoin.
Maybe the real treasure is blockchain
because it's going to change the world as
much as the Internet did in the 1990s
Satoshi Nakamoto was nominated for the
Nobel Prize in economics and he has a
multibillionaire and yet no one
knows what he actually looks like.
He might not even be a
single person in the name,
may serve as a cover for a group who
came together for the sake of starting a
digital revolution on
today's buying graphics.
We're going to go over what we know about
this little known figure is what does
the theories behind his secret identity.
Okay.
In the 1980s and nineties that closest
thing you had to a cool gang of
rebellious computer hackers
was the cypherpunks.
They were computer programmers who were
interested in creating absolute privacy
in the digital world.
They specialized in creating ciphers that
were nearly impossible to break into.
Many of them were anarchists since
Libertarians who believes that everyone
should be connected online
without government interference.
Sadly, as we now know,
the Internet is anything but free you
from the watchful eyes of the NSA,
many of the cypherpunks experiments and
in the idea that the internet could be
used to send digital money
without the use of a middleman.
David trauma invented Digi cash in 1989
and he published an academic paper on
the subject, another one of the
Cypherpunks, Nick Savo created bit gold.
All of these,
they were close but no cigar.
Even though the Cypherpunks
had this idea conceived,
they couldn't actually come up with a
technical way to accomplish a true peer to
peer experience. You see, when
you're using the Internet,
your depending on your Internet service
provider and they need to abide by the
laws of each respective country.
With apps like paypal and Venmo
sending money to your friends,
it probably seems like an
instant peer to peer experience,
at least for you as the customer,
but behind the scenes these companies
still have to settle bank transactions the
old fashioned way.
This is three days worth of paperwork
through an antiquated and expensive system
called swift. If this sounds
ridiculous in this day and age,
that's because it really is.
The global digital banking system has
been long do an overhaul. Further.
After the 2008 stock
market crash the world,
it was primed and ready
for a financial revolution.
In October of 2008 someone going by the
name of Satoshi Nakamoto wrote a paper
called Bitcoin,
a peer to peer electronic cash system.
He began to email all the cypherpunks
asking if they were willing to help him
create his idea of a new system
that he called blockchain.
This was a computer network
that she truly was peer to peer.
There would be no fear that your Internet
service provider, which shut it down.
The blockchain is basically an accounting
system that records all transactions
on a public ledger.
Instead of the U s dollar value would be
exchanged in a digital currency called
bitcoin.
New bitcoins have to be created by mining,
which is a process of computers attempting
to solve a difficult math problem.
Once the cipher is solved, the minor is
rewarded with a bitcoin. In the beginning.
One bitcoin was only worth fractions of
a penny back then and he run of the mill
computer you just got from your
local best buy could handle mining,
bitcoin and anyone could
receive and deposit the currency
in that digital wallet.
The blockchain itself exists in the cloud,
which is a sort of hive minds that does
not exist in any physical location.
This means that no government in the
world is the ability to shut it down
because as long as there are minors
somewhere out there in the welds you were
running the blockchain,
bitcoin will continue to exist.
Even though it was the solution there
had been searching for many of the
cypherpunks ignored.
Satoshi Nakamoto is ideas.
The thing is they weren't kids anymore.
They were in their forties and 50s and
they'd already tried and failed to make
that own digital currencies.
The idea of bitcoin.
It was so radical that it seems like
something out of a science fiction movie,
but one could be program
are from California named
how Finny saw its potential
and he was the first best and to
take Sitoshi neck Emoto seriously.
He asked to work on the bitcoin project
for free and so on January the third
2009 bitcoin was first launched health,
any institution knack in America who
have never met face to face and they've
never spoken over the phone.
Now can Mojo left his email address on
the big coin website allowing anyone's
contact him with any questions that
they might have about the project.
This led to many,
the program is joining in and
helping them in the very beginning.
This idea of it was only
popular to anarchists and
Libertarians who had the goal
of living their lives free
from governmental rule.
While they are small in number,
this community is incredibly passionate
about their philosophies to this very
day. They were the first ones do cling
on to this bitcoin revolution and as many
calls Satoshi Nakamoto hero.
Yeah,
of course.
Once the word got out that bitcoin
was a way to transfer money privately,
it was almost immediately adopted by
criminals and 2011 a website called the
Silk Road appeared in a
web browser called Tor,
which is used to browse the dark web.
The founders are in
kingpin of the Silk Road,
goes by the name of dread pirate Roberts,
like the character from
the princess bride.
You can buy anything on the Silk Road
including human slaves and hit orders from
assassins. Since most of these
transactions, they're all done in bitcoin.
In 2013 a 29 year olds man named Ross
Albrecht was arrested under suspicion of
being the dread pirate Roberts.
In 2015 he was convicted of conspiracy
to transfer narcotics since,
since he was labeled as an evil king.
Then he was given not just one but two
life sentences plus an additional 40
years without the possibility of parole.
The average silkroad drug dealer and
he got five to 10 years behind bars.
Most people in the cryptocurrency
community believed that
old was just a patsy
and the real dread pirate
Roberts has gotten free.
The FBI seized Russell breaks cache of
bitcoins and auction them off to the
highest bidder while all bricks
was in solitary confinement.
Someone else logged in to the dread
pirate Roberts comes on the Silk Road.
Either he had passed the account to
another King Ben or they truly did arrest
the wrong man, so one's a bit coin that
started getting a lot of bad press.
The Towson I can moto was very upset to
see how his project was being used for
evil.
The last nine person to have communicated
with Sitoshi Nakamoto was Gavin
Andresen programmer who
looked up to NAC and motor.
It was his mentor and hero when the
FBI and CIA came looking for Sitoshi
Nakamoto.
Gavin Andresen agreed to speak with
them about bitcoin on the mysterious
founders behalf because he wanted
to help educate them about water.
Blockchain technology actually is this
must have fries and Dac and motor because
he pick cut off ties with the rest of
the original bitcoin team. Since then,
Satoshi Nakamoto is bitcoin public wallet
addresses remained untouched even in
2017 when the price balloon
to $20,000 per coin.
He has never withdrawn his money.
He should be one of the
richest men in the world's,
but he has decided not to spend a
penny of it for people who were paying
attention to bitcoin since its inception.
Many founders that they could
turn blockchain technology
into an opportunity to
make their own businesses.
Since the code for blockchain was open
source and free for anyone to use,
it could be improved and builds
upon boy genius. Vitalik.
Buterin was just 17 years old when he
began to learn how to code blockchain and
founds in Bitcoin magazine.
He gains a loss of respect from people
who were much older than he was and he
proposed a new project called ethereum.
This wasn't just another coin
to compete with bitcoin there.
It was far faster and cheaper runs.
People could build their own
businesses upon the ethereum platform.
These were called ICO or initial
coin offerings. Unfortunately though,
the vast majority of these crypto currency
businesses were and still are total
scams,
the government's agencies of the world,
they suddenly had a whole lot more to
worry about than just bitcoin because on
educated people around the world
started to dump their life savings into
fraudulent companies in the hopes
that it would be the next bitcoin.
At the moment,
there are very few alternative coins
that are legitimate companies and not
simply scamps. At the
time. This video was neat.
The number two cryptocurrency
in the world is riddle.
This is because there aren't actual
corporation led by the former CEO of AOL,
Brad Garlinghouse.
They have offices in multiple countries
where they have hundreds of employees
working to educate major corporations
about what blockchain can help them do.
They are already working hands in
hands with the Federal Reserve and have
contracts with over 200 banks who have
agreed to use their currency. XRP.
You just settled trillions of dollars
in bank transactions in the future.
Well,
many of the leaders in traditional finance
and tacker trying to figure out how
to incorporate blockchain in the
real wells. There are the purists.
You still passionately believe in the
anarchist ideals of the cypherpunks and of
Satoshi Nakamoto.
Many of these original followers were
made multimillionaires by their initial
investments.
While some of these people who are
coders who understood the blockchain
technology, the majority of them had no
background in computer science at all,
and we're supporting bitcoin simply
for the fact that they believed in its
philosophy.
[inaudible] Moto.
It was never the CEO of bitcoin because
it's not even a business entity.
He was never trying to be a leader,
but the level of reverence that some
people have for him has been compared to a
cult on multiple occasions
without a leader to guide them.
Bitcoin believers debate over the
question of what would Sitoshi do?
They created an analyze this
old emails and his publications.
The reddit boards are filled with heated
debates trying to interpret Sitoshi as
words as if they're their Bible.
At this point in time,
bitcoin transactions take several hours
or even days to go through and they cost
roughly $40 in fees per transaction.
It's got to the point where it's almost
as expensive and as slow as the bolt
score banking system. The idea of
saying bitcoin will be around forever.
It's kind of like saying that dial up
internet should still be around to,
even though the TAC has been in
a serious downward spiral ends,
other companies like ripple
have drastically improved
upon blockchain technology
in recent years. Much of the bitcoin
community is just in total denial.
They continue to have blind faith in
the original bitcoin and is in a man or
group who isn't even around
anymore to give their input.
The original programmer of Bitcoin,
how Finny suffered from als,
also known as Lou Gehrig's disease.
If you aren't already aware,
this is the same year edge degenerative
disease that immobilized Stephen Hawking
is where someone's brain is fully
functional but they no longer have control
over their body.
The timeline of how Finney's condition
getting worse actually lines up with
Satoshi Nakamoto deciding to disappear.
Andy Greenberg is senior
writer at wired magazine,
made the connection and he believed
that he had cracked the case.
So you went to interview him.
At this point,
Pal Finney was in a wheelchair
and he could no longer speak.
He could only answer yes or no questions.
Greenburg asked point blank if it's
true that he was Sitoshi knack and Moto
Finney's eyes. Glistened and
amusements anti promptly responded. No.
Even though how funny has
become a multimillionaire
from mining bitcoin in the
early days of the projects,
no amounts of money,
you could save him from the disease,
but maybe he could postpone the
inevitable on the brink of death.
Funding requested that his body be
cryogenically frozen in the hopes that
someday he would be unfrozen
and give them the cure to als.
In 2014 he passed away and his body
was transported to a lab in Arizona,
just two miles away from
health and he's home.
The FBI showed up on someone's
property with a warrant.
They dragged out a mountain with black
hair and glasses and the rest of the demo
under suspicion of being the
mysterious founder of Bitcoin,
he insisted over and over that he had
no idea what they were talking about is
full legal name. Oh, that would
be Dorian. Satoshi Nakamoto
off to the PAP RNC showed up at his
doorstep and he was falsely reported that
Dory institution now can moto.
It was the true founder of Bitcoin.
This sends him into the spotlight of the
media and he had to go on record with
the Associated Press insisting that he
did not have anything to do with the
project and that someone had clearly
taken. His name is a pseudonym today.
Dorian Nakamoto has been affectionately
titled the Fake Satoshi and members of
the community actually love him.
His face was even turned into a meme.
Many people felt sorry that he was dragged
into this and even donated bitcoins
to him as a sort of sorry for the mix up
in 2017 those donations inflated to be
worth $273,000 and he quickly
cashed out at just the right time.
Today,
Dorian Nakamoto has actually embraced
the community and he now enjoys being a
celebrity and taking photos with his fans.
Then in 2015 yes,
another potential candidates
emerged in the media.
US authorities raided the home of
an Australian man named Dr. Craig,
right in 2016 rise agreed to do multiple
press interviews claiming that he was
the real Satoshi Nakamoto.
When he gave his evidence to journalists,
they were satisfied not knowing that he
had pulled the equivalent of a technical
parlor trick. Some people will
believe, some people weren't.
And to tell you the truth,
I don't really care.
Most people don't know how easy it is to
fake this kind of proof on blockchain.
So it has been published in multiple
venues that here's the real Sitoshi
Nakamoto. But after seeing the likes of
the BBC and the economist of vouching,
Fen,
many people in the colors of Satoshi began
to believe that their messiah had for
a tans and he was back to
tell them exactly what to
do with that money during a
public interview.
Boy Genius Vitalik Buterin gave a number
of examples of our Craig Wrights could
have faked this so-called proof and gave
examples of how he should have proven
that he was the real Satoshi Nakamoto,
but he had failed to do so.
Boozer and sandy signaling theory.
It says that if you have a good way to
prove something and do you have a noisy
way to do it,
then the reason why you picked the noisy
way was because you couldn't do the
good way in the first place.
Craig Rice is in fact profiting office,
sudden claim to fame.
He is an outspoken to shame and appearing
before crowds making promises about a
bitcoin's future.
In reality,
he has started his own company and to
the promises he makes her actually not
that impressive where
the tech is concerned.
He made millions of dollars from investors
simply by claiming that he is the
real protection Akron Moto in many ways.
He seems to be bike the wizard of Oz,
but many have not been fooled.
In February of 2018 Craig rice with
sued for stealing $10 billion of crypto
currency assets from his former business
fondness. The lawsuit is still ongoing,
so at the time we're making this video,
we can't be sure of the outcome.
The journalist named Andrew O'hagan has
done a very deep dive into the Craig
right case and here's discovered that
Rice also lost a lot of money in the past
from a cryptocurrency farm called Liberty
Reserve in Costa Rica. Right? Awesome.
At face to face with Ross
Ulbricht soon before his arrest.
So why on earth would this millionaire
businessman be associating with a drug
dealer from the Silk Road? Some
people theorize that, right?
Isn't Satoshi Nakamoto at all,
and he may actually be the
true dread pirate Roberts.
There are dozens of theories of who at
Satoshi Nakamoto truly is from Elon Musk
to the NSA. One of them asks,
former ends ends at Space X.
Sahil Gupta wrote a comprehensive blog
post on medium as to why he believed that
his former boss was the
real Satoshi Nakamoto.
This caused such a stir that Elon Musk
and to tweets that he was not the founder
of Bitcoin.
Everyone of course,
has a very passionate reason for believing
that their theory is the correct one,
whoever he is, we may never have seen
Satoshi Nakamoto in the news at all,
even under another name.
It's very possible that he knew better
than to put himself in the limelight and
it would be impossible to gases identity.
Effie kept in the shadows,
but it's the Toshi neck and moto is
still alive and his, if he is true leaf,
just one man or even a group of people,
why haven't they touched those billions
of dollars that are sitting in that big
coin wallet?
Is there really a person on this planet
with the willpower to resist that kind
of temptation and what does he think
about the corrupt system that bitcoin has
become? In 2012 Satoshi Nakamoto wrote
in an email to one of the original core
developers of Bitcoin by hand.
That ripple is interesting in that
it's the only other system that does
something with trust beside
concentrated into a central server.
While she is basically saying is that
it's the only other coin he considered a
real contender and admits that it's truly
an improvement on bitcoin and his last
email,
he also rode the dude given up on bitcoin
and wanted to work on another project
without giving any details as to
what that new project actually was.
And this leads us to our final theory.
David Schwartz,
who is now the lead cryptographer ripple.
In 1988 Shults filed two patents have
a distributive computing network before
the existence of the Internet.
And in lots of ways his idea,
it was almost identical to bitcoin.
20 years before Sitoshi
Nakamoto appeared on the scene.
Shorts is no stranger to
using alias as either,
and he went by the pseudonym Joel
counts online for many years.
There is no denying that
he was intelligent enough
to come up with this on his
own. Shorts is used his
knowledge to turn the rep,
the ecosystem into a product that is far
more sustainable than bitcoin ever was.
It doesn't need to be mined.
That transactions are settled within
a few seconds in each transfer costs a
fraction of a penny banks around the
world already beginning to use the ripple
network because it's the only one that's
even remotely possible to use in the
real world. David Schwartz has an
estimated net worth of $90 million.
If ripple succeeds as much as many
believe it will and he may become a
billionaire at some point in the future.
This would serve as a rational explanation
as to why he hasn't touched the
fortune in bitcoin is because he doesn't
want the possibility that it may lead
back to him and he became so rich with
ripple that he doesn't actually need it
when presented with this theory.
David Schwartz denies it of course,
but that's probably what the
real sitoshi would totally say.
So I really hope you found their video
interesting and it was a little different
from our normal video is here with us not
really knowing anything about the man,
but they have it.
I do hope you enjoyed it.
Give it a like if you did leave us a
comment. Let me know what your thoughts,
if you're looking at
something else to check out,
why not check out my other channel called
top tens you'll find a link to that
below this video, and as
always, thank you for watching.